in Counter-Strike being an in-game
leader on a top roster is no easy task
you spend so much time thinking about
the other side that your own fragging
can take a back seat but when you don't
put up the stats that your fans expect
they can get vicious everybody respects
someone that can lead by example the
most valuable possible player is someone
that could adapt on the Fly come up with
the strats and carry their weight and
kills all at the same time I don't even
think James realizes he could actually
save he probably feels like there's
presence in the b-bomb site but the
clutch is on oh that smoke it catches
the rail and that's a little bit
unfortunate otherwise maybe you're gonna
try to put some pressure he's still
gonna go for it
[Applause]
every team wants an igl that can frag
but there's only so many seasoned
veterans with cracked aim and Beautiful
Minds to go around so some teams need to
get
creative you can see price deep in the
pit Biko far away is he gonna fight he's
got a flash hooksie into teaspoon as if
I got a moment oh they're bringing out
the big guns yeah they deployed that
secret weapon Lucy running through the
long doors with a flash from Nico to set
him up enter Rasmus hooksy Nielsen a man
who by all accounts is not the mythical
Fragger igl
oo surprise production didn't bring up
his ADR there Savage production
there it is
less ADR than he has deaths I don't even
know what that's some kind of record and
yet he's turned his greatest weakness
into a strength oopsie already counting
ring the rotation through CT fully up to
the task he gets three big money honey
because he'll form that with the MP9 and
Nico is certainly ready with all of that
information
Heidi stop there yeah you're right money
oopsie he doesn't need a drop he could
buy his own M4 he's an independent man
over the past few months the Cs go
Community has witnessed the rise of one
of the greatest memes in the game's
history all thanks to hooksy and his
performance on G2 I'm having a save is
crimbo that's actually a TK hooksy
that's the worst possible solution here
now it's gonna be modesty he's gonna
have to just try and stickers found the
other kill it's all falling apart a
classic G2 moment add that one to the
catalog I think we're gonna call vertigo
done and dusted 13-6 the morale is
broken now as the team's latest igl he
pushed the limit of what a leader stats
should look like while also pushing his
team and himself in ways that no one
expected hooksy knew that his stats
weren't great but he looked all of his
haters in the eyes and said will win
anyway seriously could smoke they got a
Molly for sandbag as well if they piece
this one together it could be perfect
there's the Molly that's one of the high
HP fantasy stepped out now it's the low
HP of hooks here jks these two they did
it before but they have to do it again
luckily for them there is an orph in the
mix as well they might not have the
information these players are both
desperately low time ticking away though
jks probably needs to strike before the
bomb is touched here low HP on the 15.
he takes down the diffuser that cancels
it can he spray again yes he absolutely
with the quad kill yeah
that you see though dude they're trying
to test our boy hooksies
so how did hooksy change the narrative
around his subpar stats how did he show
the true value of an igl while spending
so much time at the bottom of the server
and how did he Embrace csgo's latest and
greatest meme to become the Giga Chad a
poem about hooksy for the blind he is
the vision for the hungry he is the chef
for the Thirsty he is the water if hooks
he thinks I agree if hooksy speaks I'm
listening if hooksy has one fan it's me
if hooks he has no fans I don't exist at
all oh I've got goosebumps Chad that was
beautiful
[Music]
all right folks you know what time it is
before we get into The Saga of the rise
of Cs Go's greatest Giga Chad I need to
humbly ask you all to sub to the channel
and turn on notifications and if you're
a real Giga Chad you'll come watch some
of our streams right here on YouTube
okay so the legend of hooksy begins in
August 2022 when G2 Esports was a team
looking for answers after spending the
first eight months of the year mostly
floundering with their new igl Alexi B
the roster needed to make changes Alexi
B was out along with their longtime
rifler Jax hi guys my name is Jay kiss
I'd like to try out for the open raffle
roll jks who'd impressed with his
historic stand and performance win as a
part of phase was a no-brainer addition
to the roster jks was kind of first
option because instead of jacks we
needed a player like jks who is Anchor
and lurker we didn't almost looking for
any other player but G2 needed two new
players and the other name is not what
anyone expected my name is
I'm applying for the Ikea role well what
makes you think you will be better ideal
than me
you're hired
hooksy was a big question mark for G2 on
one hand he led his previous team
Copenhagen Flames to two majors even
making the playoffs in Antwerp 30
seconds left for an impeccable clutch
siphon's down on top but there it is
finally the fifth Pines the charm the
Copenhagen Flames they lift the curse
they shed their demons and burn brighter
than ever before
playoffs in Antwerp yeah we're gonna see
the flames in front of a crowd and they
do it on the other hand though there
were still plenty of unknowns with Jax
gone hooksy was the obvious player to
play entry on T side but he hadn't
historically played that role before and
it's not like his stats really inspired
a lot of confidence we are not
questioning here at least not me
personally if he deserved the chance he
definitely did but he bought his tickets
to G2 you know fair and square here he
worked for it he got the you know chance
he bought the ticket and he deserved it
right but like we spoke about this role
strange he was the least aggressive
player in Copenhagen flames and yet he
had the lowest amount of impact right in
terms of in terms of numbers right and
there were seemingly other options
available to G2 like Alex or even
boomich so why that the hell did they
settle for hooksy specifically he has
different Vision like comparing to high
jails we had before and he liked to play
more loose and with players we have in
the team I think it's good and that's
the biggest reason why we should why
we've chosen him and he is not scared to
tell to anyone like whatever in the in
the eye after practice after game and I
think we needed this kind of agile what
I do is I grab and I compare this to the
in-game leaders around him uh sorry the
in-game leaders who have either come or
gone or the other ones who are rumored
and I go well none of the names that
people can List have achieved as much as
hooksy as an in-game later in the last
six to eight months ultimately hooksy's
pedigree convinced G2 to take a shot on
him after all his low stats are pretty
common with igls you don't have to kill
if you can lead and g2's Coach X Taz
actually vouched for hooksy in an
interview with hltv where he said that
he and the team's new igl were on the
same page but fans weren't convinced
they started picking on hooksy subpar
stats immediately and things only got
worse when he finally debuted for G2
during the blast fall Premiere his third
headshot of the round but his first kill
let's go hook me up with some little
messy to put it simply hooksy
underperformed even in games where they
won buddy was going like 3 and 16 where
his teammates were dropping 30 bombs
hooksy's performances were so brutal
that it eventually spawned a meme
whenever hooksie did anything die get a
kill breathe in the direction of an
enemy twitch chat spammed the Giga
chatty mode Nico I'm honestly Springs to
life and through the smoke there it is
as they'll say dead through the back of
the head and the hedgehogs are going to
keep coming the disrespect out the gate
Henry we saw a phase attempt this if you
remember pushing down towards middle are
trying to disrespect their opponent
super workout for them too well but it's
actually working out very nicely for G2
I say that with baited okay as we are
seeing headshots Galore here towards a
banana
Rock and sock and Counter-Strike here
but hunter will come out on top he will
manage to get three kills in total a
little bit bumpy towards the end but a
clean round I suppose if you're not
familiar with the Giga Chad meme it's
based on a picture of Russian
bodybuilder Ernest kalamov and its many
variations are pretty widespread now the
idea behind the meme is that as a
perfect specimen of masculinity the
gigachad is confident that every option
they choose is the correct one obviously
and hoaxi was CS goes Giga chat Duprees
honing in closer flash on the feet of
hooksey goes for the modesty fight it's
the dink sets up Booksy I can't get the
kill
zaiwu blocks him in the face despite his
clear underperformance G2 added fuel to
the meme fire using a quote from an HL
TV interview hooksy had done days
earlier although there were already
people who felt that the org was going a
bit too hard on their new igl so
hooksy's play basically became a joke
for me is the best player in the world
right now I don't want to enter to jinx
anything we we've tried that in in
Australis when we were playing a cologne
against Navi with with Zeus and I think
it was the second time in his career
that he ever got 30 kills because we
were trying to exploit him so never
again so hooks is the best player in the
world right now and we'll try everything
to avoid him in fact you couldn't even
go on the Global Offensive subreddit
without seeing at least a single thread
talking about his low stats and even his
most modest plays continued to be met
with cries of gigachad but to be fair
hooksy's comment about not needing to
frag wasn't necessarily wrong see the
meme in the community is that Nico kind
of usurps his igls whether it's true or
not the fans have often felt that he
does best with the firmer hand on the
server between Nico and modesty alone G2
already had a lot of Firepower if hooksy
could just make sure that everyone got
what they needed and maybe pick up a few
scraps of Glory here and there it could
probably still work out and at this
first event it kind of did unfortunately
for them the blast season doesn't get
any easier once they get there jks and
Nico locking it in on the cross he comes
out through his own smoke but his backs
turn to Nico and that is a lethal error
a fantastic showing out of Hunter and
Nico G2 made fourth at blast maybe they
didn't push to new heights but it was a
respectable performance and they earned
a spot at the fall finals as a result
okay so the good that was the goal for
the for the tournament for us and uh
I'll be honest after the first few days
of practice and how hard it was for me
to transition into uh speaking English
all the time I I wouldn't say I didn't
believe it but at the same time I felt
it was more like tougher than I thought
it would be so I'm really happy that we
actually pulled through in the end but
none of this gave G2 fans any more
insight into the hooksy pickup since
through it all he was still playing like
an absolute bot actually lost his vision
in the smoke and still came back but
that frag oh it gets hooksy instead
perfect guy just a thousand ways to die
with hooksy and sure given all of their
extra responsibilities igls often get a
bit of a pass in terms of their personal
stats if it means success for the roster
as a whole but hooksy's stats were
pushing that leniency to its absolute
limits thankfully there were some
obvious changes to g2's gameplay
including some setups that he refined on
his previous teams so first this is from
his time in Copenhagen Flames he first
throws a top connector smoke and take a
look at the setup here and I want you
just to remember a lot of these details
so top connective smoke here two players
towards mid two players that ramp one
player Palace take a look at the map
where you see the same thing two players
here towards this mid position two
players that ramp one at Palace this is
definitely going to be an a split once
again and the details are very similar
you'll see the path in here same thing
one player towards the bottom side of
middle one player going along this
catwalk side
and then Hunter he's going to do that
Peak towards that connected side this
time he actually loses the fight well
actually he still does the same thing he
goes right into connector to trade that
kill and you'll see right on the map
once again something very similar
pressure here choices connect your side
towards a it's now down to these players
that Aid to put pressure into a now
and that's exactly what happens jcast is
smoked out so it's all Nico to actually
come out of the palace and find this
kill on the player towards ticket and
hooksy just does the exact same thing
goes through the connected Smoke on the
left side trying to catch a potential
jungle player doesn't see anything but
he still wants to get the space so he's
gonna go and go for it but you'll
basically see that this Strat is
basically almost the same as what he ran
in Copenhagen flames and this is really
uh you know kind of the influence that
hooksy has brought plus once fans had a
chance to hear hooksy's point of view he
became an instant favorite he was honest
about his performance and about his role
in the team well I look at it in this
way that of course I would like to shoot
more and I feel like I should as well
obviously you can't kill two people and
expect to win every time but at the same
way I look at it like if I killed 10
more in both the first and the third
would we have one probably not uh so
yeah I don't know I'm of course
disappointed with my video performance
but at the same time I don't feel like
that's what we should take away from
this game for a dude that was being
memed into Oblivion for bottom fragging
hooksy always kept his cool he accepted
the criticism laughed about it and vowed
to improve I take things pretty lightly
I don't really like all the way back
from all my other teams I've got a lot
of faith for my individual performance
for example and
I don't really care too much like most
of the people who talk to me who talks
trash doesn't really know what they're
talking about so I'm fine with that and
uh yeah I'm just going to do my way and
then we'll see how it goes that endeared
him to fans and their support propelled
the Giga Chad to new heights more than
anything that was a series for G2 where
you know modesty didn't really do that
much and they still had a comfortable
win the the rifles were doing the brunt
of the work work and hooks he had more
than 10 kills and what more can you have
another miracle well who is having a
good time with it uh that was one thing
we didn't get to see yesterday yeah
apparently a giga Chad of sorts in that
series against mibr and ESL pro league
hooksy was pretty close to an even KD
ratio but he went deeply negative in the
next as the rest of G2 had to defeat big
for him even so hooksy pulled off a big
play that kept his team alive in
overtime well luckily for them there is
an open the mix as well they might not
have the information these players are
both desperately low time ticking away
though JK's probably needs to strike
before the bomb is touched here low HP
under 15. he takes down the diffuser and
cancels it can he spray again
see with the quad kill
things up at 17-17 around where they
took a deficit to kick things off Hunter
dropped and they limped in towards his
side but it looked like they had no
chance in the retake and he delivered
but then something strange happened
maybe it was the fresh Mediterranean air
in Malta maybe hooksy switched his
settings and something just clicked I'm
kidding that never works remember
friends don't let friends change their
settings every round but for whatever
reason after that big series hooksy
looked different first against for the
win he was plus 10 even though both Maps
were actually complete blowouts and then
unexpectedly he somehow was voted player
of the match on hltv hoaxy managed a
positive hltv rating on both Maps
against FaZe and again became player of
the match and after a 2-0 win over
Outsiders hooksy was voted player of the
match for a third time since he didn't
really carry any of the maps it was
clearly just an attempt to keep the
gigachad meme pumping and whether or not
the fans that voted for invented or not
they actually manifested another scarier
hooksie yeah you see a fast approaching
with middle here they'll be just pushing
through the Obama to utility and hooksey
with a lovely double kill there towards
middle that's about as good as it gets
Chad and that is the perfect t-side
midday look at all the util the donuts
smoker now the one for hooksion
what they're hoping for
Rico has been swung on and so now hooks
he does have to win this with the spawn
that turns an infuser he needs one more
pulloutsy with the 1v2 oh yeah they're
trying oh see though the smoke actually
a little bit early but it was absolutely
perfect he's out of bullets so he's
gonna keep going obviously beautiful
defense in Ace to close up the round
with that's gonna get G2 fired up G2
eventually dropped out of EPL after
losing to Vitality but hooksy he was now
firmly the geiger Chad no it's fun to
watch other matches as well because now
I just see my name in twister all the
time no matter who's playing yeah like
it was that like like I didn't see it
coming I'm casting this week last week
all I see is your name I'm like what is
going on it's so weird it doesn't matter
where I go like I look on YouTube I see
my face I look on on WhatsApp in our
private group for the team they are
posting memes about me all the time I
look on Twitter I see my face I look on
Facebook it doesn't matter where I look
ESO added an emote of the meme to their
twitch Channel and it saw plenty of use
thanks give me your famous I'll take all
the bullets it's hooksy's world and no
one's getting
in touch
hooksy even got the super Stidham
treatment over a period of six
consecutive Maps he maintained a 1.0
rating or better something that he had
never managed against teams of this
caliber but it wasn't just his own stats
that were up though modesty also notably
popped off during this time all thanks
to hooksy I think he feels good with us
uh his calls and his playstyle is his
good and
I feel better to play with him than
before with the world lineup and when
the new G2 Esports lineup finally played
their first RMR game it was a 160
clapping of ecstatic hooksy was
legitimately at the top of the
leaderboard but for all the gigachad
fans this was the absolute highest of
highs before the inevitable lowest of
lows high end with the frag modesty with
it all to do he gets the wall bang in
and hunts for the last man he's dropped
the kid needs the ace Only Hits the leg
show the USP comes out but it's a cold
day now game of legion of eliminated G2
from the European RMR as they stay alive
Bound for the major G2 took a narrow
loss against game religion at the RMR
missing their chance to attend the major
and across the three Maps hooksy was
unfortunately
-23 since then Coach ekstaz has Departed
the team and it's not clear how the
roster will change but despite his
recent stumble hoaxi has proved to be
more than csgo's most beloved meme he's
also provided us one of the most
inspiring stories the game has seen in a
while hooksy ascended from ridicule to
reverence he didn't need to frag to win
and he was brave enough to say that out
loud but then he fragged anyways
quickly into this b side again last time
it did work out this time hooksie
delivers two quick kills as they try to
get beyond that fan so things to an
immediate halt hooks he goes ahead body
bags a third and then further damage
onto head trick Hunter getting closer
and closer can't manage to put down sdy
but now there's so much support here
that it should be G2 to just finish it
off and how about a hooksy ace to end
the first 15. on a more serious note it
is clear why fans were so Swept Away by
hooksy Mania he just kept it real so
whenever he pulled a rabbit out of his
hat or put up a decent rating we knew
that hooksy's excitement was real too
hooksy is a reminder that every player
even a 27 year old igl leading two of
the hottest stars in the game right now
can find ways to improve and when they
do they should get every bit of credit
for that one final question the most
important one whose world is it oh it's
hooks as well hell yeah it is
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock